All right,
let me just have this dense thick heel
scan that curls over on each side like a
human flip flop.
You could hide a q tip from where the,
the ankles,
the calves go into the ankle if you can
just tuck one in there and not even see
it.
We were talking about that too.
The thing that you least have a sympathy
for someone who's overweight.
You know,
I,
I sympathize with people who have
glandular problems,
but if you're just a fat fuck,
glutton ising all day,
uh,
if you're a fucking faggot shit,
say that again.
Have you ever fucked a fat chick?
I'm going to give you a second chance.
I'm sure.
Sure.
I blocked it out.
No,
that actually is a little bit like,
hey,
it's more chick and it actually,
you know,
you get sweaty ingredients like you're
fucking more woman.
And I kind of enjoyed it was different.
Do you feel more comfortable with your
body too?
Because you look,
listen,
bitch,
you know,
you're,
I didn't think of it that way.
It was kind of like,
oh,
there's skin and boobs everywhere and
ass everywhere.
You ever feel uncomfortable about any
one of these folds in her stomach?
It was just weird,
like I don't want to do it again,
but it was definitely interesting.
Who was it that told us that only fucks
with a shirt on?
Was it already?
Probably Duncan.
I don't remember.
Whatever.
I guess if you were,
if you were banging.
I don't think it's all right.
I think.
I think I'm incorrect.
If you're banging,
it might've been Louie ck.
Oh,
that I can see that now.
I think he actually has a bid on it
actually.
I'm pretty sure that's it.
Yeah,
I think Louis has a bid on it.
Um,
you know,
if you're,
if you're fucking offend,
check like you can like loosen up,
you know,
if you're banging like some super hot
alpha female with perfect shape.
Like why is she even lend me?
Fuck her.
This is ridiculous.
Like I'm not even worthy.
But if it's a faculty like bitching,
good as you can make fun of.
Yeah.
There's definitely.
I mean,
in culturally,
you know,
there's some,
there's some cultures that still,
there's a lot of dudes who like,
I'm fat that like I have a friend who
likes girls and he always jokes around
Sam Aaa.
He jokes about it,
he likes them thick,
he likes something.
He goes,
I like a thick girl.
It was just like say it out loud,
like a big,
like a big ass,
you know.
And he's hilarious about it.
That's what he likes,
man.
That's his type of woman always has been
and he's not faking it.
That's what he likes,
you know,
everybody's got their own thing.
So that's a,
that's a fucking a weird thing.
Like when someone's got a little little
twist,
a little twist and what they're
attracted to go to fucking look a long
foot,
big foot,
don't want a wide foot.
But I look a girl with the long foot.
Yeah,
yeah.
I
have friends who will look at a girl's
feet almost first and they'll be like,
oh no,
no,
look at her.
She's got like a size 10,
you know,
and they'll just be out.
So the big theater bat or like weird
toes,
like with week chins and weak eyebrows.
If a girl is a weak chin or a week
either.
Really Small Chins are disturbing.
Disturbing.
I don't like it.
There's something.
Something wrong with you genetically.
Like if you're really missing a check
because he reminds me of like a frog or
something.
It's odd.
It's an oddity like why is your lower
jaw so small or do you not have to chew
things?
The more evolved than me.
Are you in the next stage where we're
gonna be eating liquid fruit,
blow that out and do a bubble and make a
nice song from your mouth.
What is that?
Is that evolution?
And they more evolved than us.
I don't know.
But what's up?
And also eyebrows.
I don't know about you browse bugged,
bugging when chicks have like really
like drawn on eyebrows or like just,
you know,
no eyebrow it all.
It's just,
it bugs the fuck out.
Why did chicks trim their eyebrows?
We don't give a fuck.
They don't even know if a girl has big,
bushy eyebrows.
We don't give a fuck.
I just got to take care of in the Middle
Brow,
but you know what,
if a girl is really hot and she's got a
uni brow,
who gives a fuck?
I can tolerate a uni brow.
Yeah.
You just pretend she some crazy Israeli
bitch that just got out of the secret
service over there,
over here spying on you.
But she falls in love and you're
banging.
I don't think any brand would bother me
at all.
Man.
Hairy legs are tripped up facial hair.
The girl,
when I was really young,
uh,
who was,
um,
she was going to an all girls school.
She's going to an all girls college and
her and her friends wouldn't shave their
legs.
They were like super feminist hippie
checks and this just did not work out.
The conversations that we had where it
was like,
they,
they went to this completely all girl
school that was like super,
like super ultra liberal,
ultra socialist ideals and the view of
the world was very strange and they
wouldn't shave.
Why should women have to shave?
Shave?
Like how about we both shaved?
If the only way to get you to shave is
that I have the shale.
I'll fucking shave.
I don't mind having shaved legs.
I think it's weird,
but I'll do it if you'll do it.
I can't fuck you.
Hobbit lady.
You got hair on your feet.
You know,
that's just the trip man.
Yeah.
Girls don't be having here on your feet.
Please stop that.
But that's been.
I mean this female's shaving has been
going on for thousands of years.
Right?
But what is the reason for that?
Is there an evolutionary reason?
Why are we so much more attracted to
less hair and why his hair disgusting to
us.
Is it a hygiene thing for pussy?
Right?
It must be a hygiene thing,
right?
Like you got all that crazy here.
I don't know if you,
you,
you don't even know what the fuck is in
there.
You don't know what's cleaner.
Visual creatures too.
So at the.
But some guys like hairy pussies,
hairy pussies on the comeback.
I mean Harry is very 2010,
so Ayesha Gray and some of these girls
and they're,
they're rocking it.
They got the bus,
but they cut it off right at the top,
you know,
I mean they don't go all the way through
to the.
So the little top Bush,
but they don't hair butthole Bush go.
Yeah.
So what do they do?
They wax around all that laser and laser
just keep a landing patch or tweezed
whole triangle.
Is that
like a defiance thing?
Like I'm going to redefine my sexuality.
I think it's just that people get so
accustomed.
The one thing that the new is hot,
probably it'll go in 10 years.
So gray fascinates me
and one of the reasons why she
fascinates me is because she's like the
girl that like somehow or another is I'm
free of the porn and more into moral
like of mainstream [inaudible] people's,
you know,
people's thoughts.
You know what I'm saying?
Like she's not just thought,
she's like,
she's like elevated,
she's left the just the total porn
world.
And she's permeated regular pop culture.
You know?
And it's strange when something like
that happens,
like how does one do that?
You know,
there's always like,
there's people that are like super
successful at something like Lance
Armstrong,
boom,
there's the guy,
he's the guy rides the bike,
you know,
and Jenna Jameson,
there's the super porn star,
you know,
she's the one and then there was a few
that get through the traci lords that
get through and then other people know
about them,
you know.
But Sasha gray is one,
she's a unique one.
She is.
And it's interesting because she's on
the very hardcore side of,
of,
of the business too.
I mean she's no holds barred.
I mean she,
whatever,
whatever she's down with and she.
But she kinda does it in a way where
she's like,
I want to explore all of the sides of
sexuality,
including the dark side.
So she kinda has owned it from the
beginning.
I think at that.
That's made it better.
You don't feel like Sasha,
you know,
our poor Sasha,
you like Sasha was doing what she wants
to do and she's doing it on camera.
So that I think has helped her out a lot
and then she got a big break with that.
Uh,
Steven Soderbergh film.
Did you see that as,
as a little tough to watch the whole
thing?
But it was,
it was cool.
I would,
yeah,
I would have liked it as a short movie,
you know,
like she reluctant to say it.
So I do know Sasha,
you know,
some of these girls will,
she was an awesome actor,
will look what you had to work with.
Well it was a cool feeling,
you know,
but you can't drag that on for an hour
and a half.
It's what's the cool feeling?
What is the movie about?
It's kind of this very dark kind of
artistic,
you know,
analysis of a,
of a call girl,
you know,
and how that interaction is.
But it could have been done with one
scene.
Like you get it,
you get,
you get the feeling you get how this
interaction goes.
So in the girlfriend experience,
is she providing like an intimate call
girl experience that it's like having a
girlfriend?
Is that promises?
Exactly.
I saw like two minutes of it once on
television about right.
Really minutes was the last to talk to
this guy and hugging him and then they
cut the black and I was like,
what the fuck is that?
Just kind of a snippet that lasts a
little bit too long.
That's a fucking strange thing,
man.
You ever have a buddy that's in love
with a prostitute?
I've had guys fall in love with a
stripper.
The t pains.
Well,
I had a friend who was in love with a
prostitute.
He was a guy used to play pool with a
very nice guy,
but he was unfortunate looking and uh,
he did not do very well with the ladies
and he would go to this massage parlor
and get jerked off by this one and a,
it was like one of those creepy massage
parlors,
you know,
like it wasn't really a massage parlor
and like,
you know,
they like rub your back and then just
go,
what's up?
Pull your Dick out,
let's do this.
And uh,
he wanted to ask her out to dinner
outside and she wouldn't go out with
them.
And he was trying to figure out like
he's asking me what I should do at the
magic words are,
what should I do to get her to come out
with me?
I really would like to see her outside
of the club.
And I was like,
Oh,
you're on your own.
So the threads like that,
there's so many things wrong with what
you're trying to do.
I mean,
yeah.
Okay.
Well,
okay,
what happens then?
You become boyfriend and girlfriend and
she agrees,
looks and no more in the mouth.
Only hand jobs from now on.
Like do you guys,
do you come to an agreement or just
accept the fact that this is what she
does at work?
That's work for her.
That's tough.
Strange,
right?
It's strange that we're so.
It's so genetically attached.
We're so genetically attached to control
each other.
Sexuality.
You know,
you could have a wife that was a massage
therapist and she could be a great deep
tissues.
She'll let her,
let her rub your Bob.
Really,
your wife's going to rub me.
She could've rubbed me with oil all over
my back.
And am I going to grown while she's
rubbing me?
I'm going to go,
oh yeah.
Uh,
so good.
And you're going to be cool with that.
Yeah.
It's okay because it's just rubbing your
back.
But if she rubs your Dick and you make
those same noises,
I mean,
basically she's doing the same thing.
She just massaging you,
but it just feels way better,
but it feels too good.
Too much.
You're going to get psychologically
attached to her rubbing on your deck.
You can't do that.
We draw the line.
It's a funny.
It's a funny paradigm and it's certainly
always been one sided.
I mean,
I wouldn't even want to check who does
massages.
Yeah.
I would feel creeped out.
I get a bunch of my buddies come over
and,
and massage.
I'm like,
what could you imagine if you had a
check that was doing massages and you're
really into.
And then one of your buddies started
getting massages from her.
I can't,
Bro.
What the fuck?
What are you doing?
And they have a nice eight ladies and
give them a hug.
Thank you so much for the big tip.
Please.
You're the best.
I'm not the best.
He's the best.
He kill me.
I can't wait for the next one.
When's our next one?
When's the next one?
When we doing this again,
stop and you're like,
Hey,
what are you guys fucking like?
What's going on over here?
Goddammit,
you're causing pleasure with your hands
and rubbing his ass cheeks.
What's up?
It's interesting because you have those,
those conversations like would you tell
me if mark got a hard on while you were
massaged them?
What are you saying?
Stop it.
Yeah.
There's a real distinction for me.
I mean,
and there's some people who won't let
their girls get a massage like I have.
Yeah,
for sure.
You know what I mean?
They won't let them get a massage from
another male Zeus,
you know,
and that's some Taliban type shit,
but you know,
and then it just as a whole variety of
different,
you know,
different levels of what people are
comfortable with,
you know,
that's fucking seen you naked and robin.
But yeah,
it's good to look at your booth.
Yeah,
for sure.
For sure.
I mean it's,
it's an interesting paradigm.
I mean,
for me,
I think I wouldn't,
we have,
you know,
me and my girl have a very,
like very open,
honest,
you know,
relationship and she killed him.
He was like,
don't respect,
we respect each other's ability to just
want to go out and experience things.
But Chris,
Marcus's Tampax is brought to you by the
fleshlight.
Please continue with it.
But there would be,
there's a,
there's a real hard line between like
that.
Like I could,
you know,
I'm totally cool with her getting
massaged and even in like some perfect
circumstance where there was some unit
who needed to manually get her off at
some point.
I think I would be cool with that.
But at no point,
well you know,
whatever they're doing,
they don't exist anymore,
be cool with.
But do they still exist?
They should chop your balls off.
Some situation where it was very
mechanical.
She goes in for a service he
mechanically gets right.
But at the point where it's like he's
lusting and she's lost a mare.
That's when the,
that's when the board,
that's where the fucking hard line is
Bloomberg at about it.
And they'll last just physical.
Yeah,
no,
it's for me.
I can make the connection.
It's the same as rubbing the back or
doing something like that is the same as
you
to jerk off salon.
Go there.
Just some girl just rubs your balls that
hot oil and jerks you off and that's it.
Nothing.
Nothing was going on.
She kind of fairly mechanical.
Thank you.
That was great.
That was awesome.
I got rid of that.
Not like you go out and talk about your
childhood and I don't even know my dad.
Oh my God.
I don't know my dad either.
That's where they've seen.
No,
your hands laying in the field looking
up at the stars.
Fuck all that,
man.
That's just bullshit.
They're good guys.
The real question is going to be what
happens when we create artificial people
and fuck them and are people even going
to bother with relationships?
That's the real question.
You are on the brink of this with this
flashlight thing because now you guys
are the first people that have created
an effective artificial vagina.
All those other ones are bullshit.
All those blow up dolls.
Those are for Bachelor Party gag gift
bags.
All right.
Those are silly.
Nobody really fucks blow up dolls.
If you do,
it's not good.
You're better off jerking off.
You might fuck one once,
but they're not good.
Yup.
You guys have engineered a true
artificial vagina,
but this is just step one.
Remember when tvs,
when you go over your grandfather's
house and the TV was this big giant ass
fucking cabinet and the TV itself was
only like 11 inches across and you need
this fucking monstrous piece of
furniture with tubes and shit.
The bag of wires and memory,
sometimes sparks would come out the back
and you'd have to open up that there was
a particle board back to it and you
unscrew it and pull it back and look
inside the bowels of this fucking beast.
Now look at it.
You can watch your little iphone slips
in your pocket,
man,
and it's way higher resolution.
So much better.
Much better experience watching a movie
on your iphone than it is one of those
stupid tvs or an I pad.
Jesus Christ.
Yeah,
the ipad of the fake pussies coming.
Hopefully.
Uh,
hopefully.
Flashlight will be the ones.
Do you think.
So are you guys working with genetic
engineers?
Are you on the cusp of nanotechnology?
Well,
you know what I mean?
All of that.
That's kind of.
Yeah,
a golden goose.
Like the more realistic you can get it
interactive,
you know,
like fully people have tried to do it
but no one's done it well yet.
So obviously we're looking into it.
I mean things have to evolve.
I mean a flashlight looking into
robotics.
Yeah.
Well to a certain one.
Robotics just said just leave it.
Yeah,
I mean I don't want to get too much into
it,
but we've certainly explored all those
different things.
Even making it so that they can register
your performance so you could almost,
you know,
log in and see your performance is
compared to somebody else on your
machine courts.
How do you register?
You have high scores like high score.
You are devaluing the personal
experience too.
You're taking it too far,
man.
Two thousand strokes shouldn't be like
three.
This is a,
you're not fucking a person who is
trying to make feel good.
You're trying to shoot him
load.
I,
if I do this 10 times that I'm like,
why is it taking so long?
You know,
you should have,
you should have like fleshlight pants
for gay guys that like the,
there's like a thing like that.
The end of the fleshlight.
So it goes on.
They're assholes.
When other guys fuck the other guy.
It feels better.
You know,
like it.
Like it feels like a pussy adapter for
another guy's asshole.
How do you know that?
They don't like the feeling of guys.
Assholes.
I don't know.
I'm just saying mix it up a little bit.
They only have one type dude is fucking
you in the buddy's fucking you in the
butt.
All right.
This is kind of a filter for that.
Something rather disturbing is that
actually happened except uh,
the guy just put the fleshlight straight
in his butt.
Oh really?
I didn't see that.
But our flesh Jack team informed me
there was a video.
This video is a video.
Guys stuffed the flashlight up his
button and another guy fucked the flush
side.
Would that,
would that make you gay?
I'm not sure about that if you do fish
in the but it's gay.
Listen,
if you.
Yeah,
but I'm saying if a guy fucks you,
your flashlight.
Okay.
See if you stuck a flashlight up your
ass that's gay.
Or if the guy fucks your flashlight,
it's touching.
Is he getting at what you're saying?
Can you just fucking a rubber vagina?
It's gay.
If you're somehow touching a guy getting
okay,
what if you don't touch them?
What if you just assume like a high
mountain guide?
Spread your legs apart.
He keeps his legs closed.
Want me to say no for a reason was the
queer queer?
That would be weird.
You know,
one of our most popular selling units,
it's called the stamina training unit
though this.
Well,
the concept is basically that your hand
doesn't feel anything like posting,
so it doesn't prepare you to have sex.
So there's a lot of anxiety,
performance anxiety,
people who don't last long enough to
last longer.
So you know,
we've been able to give them a product
that's very like highly sensitive inner
canal so they can use it and get a
little bit more prepared.
And sensitize the people love it.
Like we get feedback like,
man,
thank you so much.
You know,
like,
I've always had problems with this,
but now I've gotten a lot better.
Yeah.
The first time you actually stick your
dick inside a vagina.
Oh yeah.
I remember the first time I had sex.
I came in one second.
I stuck at it.
I pulled it out and there was just loads
everywhere.
Oh my God.
I barely made it.
Barely made.
Have no idea what that's going to feel
like.
The first time I blew a load I was in
shock.
I didn't even know that I wasn't.
Nobody told me Shit.
All right.
No,
my parents didn't tell me anything.
And when I was a,
I guess I was like 14 or 15,
15.
My girlfriend blooming and I busted one
in her mouth and my ears rang and I was
like,
what the hell was that?
Like,
I couldn't believe that.
Like stuff comes out of you.
Like you could feel it come on.
And you're like,
whoa.
Oh,
that's what I've been building up to it.
Yeah.
I didn't know that there was even an
orgasm thing.
I recall it being like a 32nd or
different.
A ridiculous amount that's fucking ears
rang for the first time I came,
my ears rang.
They haven't ranked sense.
Wow.
Because I never gave myself a day one
day off since.
No,
I did one time for my website.
it was like 30 days or something like
that.
I tried to do.
But yeah,
you,
you know,
you never recaptured.
It's like they say with heroin addicts
the first time they shoot heroin,
it's just insanely beautiful experience.
And from then on you're chasing the
Dragon Dragon here.
Yeah.
You know that expression?
What is that?
The first load you blow.
So like it's good as it gets.
Kids love it,
enjoy it.
But the experience is so rough that it's
terrible.
I mean,
you're just nervous.
I remember,
man,
I remember the first time I'm trying to
figure out how to use this condom and
I'm going into the bathroom and I'm just
like,
it's not working.
Right.
And she's in the bed and she's ready and
I was like literally like the face was
hot and I just came out and just gave
up.
I was like,
I'm sorry.
We got to come up with a different
paradigm to make this happen.
Like,
you know,
and eventually you figure it out and
work.
But that first time is fucking brutal to
talk about.
What do you think about these fighters
that hold off for.
That's ridiculous.
They're crazy.
They're distracting the shit out of
them.
So yeah,
that seems like a really bad at.
It's so silly.
I don't think there's no.
No writing,
no,
no tests,
no studies done ever that show a
decrease in performance due to the fact
that you're having sex.
I think the distraction that you would
get from not having sex would be way
more problematic.
That would fuck you up more.
Will up your train of thought.
You wouldn't want to fight you on it.
Get some pussy fucking late when he got
laid in eight weeks when going through
training camp.
That's crazy.
I mean it seemed.
They seemed to say that it builds
aggression that they just want to
conquer.
I'm sure it does,
but just aggression.
Do you need a fucking professional cage
fighter already?
Chances are you're aggressive.
You know,
you really need to be more fucked up
under a better ground game though,
because they always want to get on the
ground who used to fight and he used to
fuck right before he fought Tyson.
That should be the end of discussion.
Yeah,
I didn't.
I didn't understand from sexual
intercourse.
It just is a natural feeling for me.
I just had to make sure I was relaxed
before my big fights.
Those all tyson training videos are
beautiful.
The passwords,
his early fights man,
like Marvis frazier,
you're wanting.
Tamara was frazier fight.
That was a salt.
He just ran up to that regular dude and
beat the fuck out of him.
What?
His Super Alpha body.
That shit didn't even make any sense.
He came out of nowhere and got everybody
excited about fighting again for the
longest time after Mohammed Ali.
Nobody gave a fuck about boxing.
It's like the Larry Holmes era.
Everybody's like,
wow,
that's Larry Holmes was fighting pink
Thomas.
I don't even know if they ever fought,
but you know my point,
it was like,
who gives a shit?
Oh,
Tony tubs.
Who gives a shit?
Michael Dokes,
whatever.
You know that all of a sudden this crazy
motherfucker moving 100 times faster
than everybody else and just smashing
people in the face at will.
That's what we wanted to see.
We didn't want to see that.
Those fights were fights.
You want to see us salts two minutes.
You're.
It was worth it.
Not really though.
People get pissed off.
You have a bunch of friends over for
review because nobody gives a fuck about
the prelims and boxing.
That's one of the beautiful things about
the UFC.
Got a UFC card.
You're not just getting the main event,
you're getting a fuck load of other
flights and they're all well matched and
they're all people you give a shit about
are all.
They're all exciting fights,
especially the ones that actually make
the air.
So there's a bunch of shit to watch.
So if the end fight is only like 15
seconds,
you know,
like Anderson Silva and you know James
Irvin or something like Bam,
it's over.
You don't feel ripped off.
I feel like,
oh,
we saw a lot of shit before we saw those
Tyson fights.
Man.
I'd have friends saying I ain't even
bought.
The last one was 34 could circuits.
It's like,
yeah man.
But that's kind of an epic moment.
The one I missed was the one where you
lost a.
I saw because I was like,
who fucking beat the shit out of this
guy?
Buster Douglas was like 60 to one
underdog or something crazy.
Crazy.
What was the other?
He was something Nutty,
right?
It wasn't like 31 or something.
You got the.
And then I remember I watched it,
I watched the tape and I was convinced
whilst watching the tape that he was
going to win.
I'm like,
Tyson's going to win this.
I was like,
I know he's gonna win.
I know he got knocked out,
but I was watching a fucking replay of
it and I was like,
she's going to win this.
I know he's got a big fucking joke,
man.
You can't be losing ice.
It doesn't lose.
It's important that when you're a kid to
realize that there are human beings,
that everyone's just a human being
because there's a few people that just
pass that human being marked in your
brain,
you know,
like Mike Tyson or meeting somebody,
meeting some famous dude.
I met ace freely when I was a little kid
and all of a sudden he was just as dude,
you know,
ace Frehley was the lead guitarist of
kiss for people don't know.
And uh,
my uncle used to work in an advertising
agency and uh,
we're in his office,
I'm hanging out with my uncle and all of
a sudden this dude walks in and it's ace
freely.
And I was a huge kiss fan and they
didn't even have makeup on.
This is back when kiss wore makeup.
Look,
you didn't know who they are freely.
I was like,
what the fuck?
I couldn't believe that dude was right
there.
And as you get older you go,
oh,
that's just another dude.
Yeah,
like Kenny loggins.
Once I brought people like Kenny loggins
that people think that way about.
I met Kenny loggins.
Pretty cool.
Did you dance?
He's the one who plays the flute,
right?
Was He?
Oh,
not Kenny loggins.
Kenny g,
Kenny G.
I didn't meet footloose.
I met the flute.
Dude.
Does he play the flute?
What does Kenny log?
Employee clarinet or something?
Gary.
Is he the only dude to ever get that
famous from playing that instrument?
Right.
He must be a bad motherfucker.
Kenny g is like the Lance Armstrong of
the flute or whatever the fuck you.
Pied Piper was pretty popular.
What does Kenny g play?
Saxophone.
Does he put aside a little bit of sac
motors that John just have a super white
guy?
Saxophone or horrible.
Super White.
Super White Guy.
Clarinet.
Yeah.
The dance.
Again,
it was Kenny g was giant for awhile.
Man and giant with anger.
People get angry at Kenny g music.
You know like dudes like comics are
always use.
Kenny g was an awesome punchline.
If you want to shit on somebody.
No.
Why is it that it was the amount?
I think it's the emasculation that he
represented.
He represents dudes married to women.
They don't want to be married to out on
dates,
having to go to a Kenny g concert and
just sitting there and shit in a world
of shit when you can be with your
friends at the bar,
drinking and throwing darts,
talk and shit.
Watching sports and having fun.
No,
no,
no.
You had a Kenny g concert,
stupid.
And you have a jacket on because she
likes the way you look with jackets.
I like a sport jacket and he got your
fucking sport.
That's what raised the ire and you're
eating shit.
That's it.
That's the end of the show.
That was the romantic ending it with
Kenny G.
before we go July,
I brought a gift for a.
Oh,
what do you got Brian here?
What do you got?
So,
you know,
people,
people kind of overlook a lot of very
legal and very cool substances that are
available.
And uh,
so I brought you guys some Blue Lotus
oil.
Now,
as you know,
Lotus,
Lotus oil was historically prize from
the land of the Lotus eaters,
kind of gives you this euphoric feeling
and it's existed.
A lot of Hindu art work,
the lotus flower.
So it's um,
it's actually,
you know,
quite they taste like a ton of lotus oil
to make this one little vial here.
This might be,
it might be loud as I can do it.
So.
Well,
what is it?
So it's a little vial here.
Let me open this up here.
That did extract like out of thousands
and thousands and thousands of loads.
It's an actual ton of pedals to make the
pedals 2000 pounds to make that little
vial and you make a little of that and
then.
So then they make this vow is to.
Oh,
he dropped it.
So it'd be an issue.
So a large is 2000 pedals.
It must be 2000 pounds.
Yeah,
I mean I mean 2000 pound believable.
So it makes it makes sense,
like an ounce of the oil and what does
it look like in a room like this fucking
time.
So it was very pricey.
So I took that,
I actually review it on my blog where
you pull it down to us and you can check
it out.
And I took it.
Yeah.
Have you had a third one?
But you've had about.
I had about a half of a mile.
It kind of comes out tufts.
So I gave it a stiff shake because that
what you,
you.
This was full and there was no,
no,
this is brand new.
This is brand new.
It's brand new.
So this is how it comes.
It comes out for took maybe maybe about
half of that,
maybe took about half of that and it was
pretty Rad.
You feel you feel very euphoric and you
know,
you,
you're everything,
all your sensations feel good and it's
not overpowering.
It's not something that like takes you
and hit you with a hammer.
But when you say I love you,
your girlfriend,
you really mean it,
you know,
like listen,
I really need all the time.
Not like you really mean it,
but it's like you really feel it.
You know what I'm saying?
Like you feel the emotion,
really feel it all the time.
Dude.
But it's like you man,
I'm a problem for women.
Some crazy dreams I dreamed.
I was like,
ah,
never dreams this dream as a vampire
playing basketball,
doing shots back steam out from
underneath the basket and just reject
some dude and Shaq dunk on vampire.
Super relaxing,
very relaxing you for like very kind of
Cathartic.
Like you could still function.
Totally.
It was very lucid and stuff.
Do you feel intoxicated at all or not
really?
You just feel it like in a bad ass mood
and it's almost like the stuff that
troubles you,
they go away.
What about you?
Are you,
are you comfortable that your reaction
time?
Would it be this?
I Siam Yeah.
I mean you'd be able to drive and it
doesn't have that kind of artificial
feeling that some of the other opiates
and sedatives and stuff kind of allergic
that lotus though.
And you're like,
oh shit.
I know shit.
I didn't even find out if you're
allergic to Lloyd gay tests,
do you like Kenny g dot?
You can't take this shit.
And on that note,
that's a perfect way to end this.
Thank you very much.
Chris,
that was a lot of fun.
Thanks for the podcast.
Fleshlight fleshlight.dot,
dot,
dot.dot
com.
Pick one up.
And unlike we said,
well Brian and I have both fucked up and
we give them two thumbs up.
It is
way better than just jerking off.
I have a new segment to that bit my
mind.
My bid on the fleshlight is growing very
strong.
Anyway.
Thank you everybody for tuning in.
I will be at,
which just killed it.
I will be.
There we go.
I'm at the,
the um,
where is it?
The Galaxy Theater in Santa Ana.
That's my next gig.
Oh actually,
no,
I'm in London,
but Brian doesn't have this up on the,
uh,
the youth stream page.
Oh,
ustream periods change that shit.
So it says I'm in London at the
Leicester Square theater,
but those two shows Thursday and Friday
of next week.
But they're sold out already.
Sorry.
Pitches you snooze you lose.
And then the galaxy theater in Santa
Ana.
October 22nd.
What do you plan?
You going to say?
Well,
you're going to play a deaf onto it or
a.
sure Diane would.
That's my new favorite man would die
antwoord it's,
I'm South African,
a band,
and it means the answer don't hurt these
guys,
they got a bunch of good shit.
They got a bunch of good shit and they
got stupid tattoos and they're ugly as
fuck.
Dude.
Love it.
Um,
tomorrow we'll have another podcast
tomorrow,
probably a two to 3:00
PM Pacific with the lovely and talented
Mr Duncan trussell.
Well,
we will discuss how the UFO are coming
and the government is preparing us.
We've got some new important
information.
Ladies and gentlemen.
See that big rubber alien pussy.
That shit is real.
We're going to tell you everything
tomorrow.
Thank you everybody for tuning into the
podcast.
As always,
we appreciate it very much and we love
you bitches.
Thank you.